we're talking with former governor of
California gray davis how is President
Obama doing on the national debt I think
he is making progress and he's got his
priorities right the only way we're
going to get the debt under control to
put people back to work and grow our
economy so in short term we need to put
people back to work get them feeling
good about the American dream again good
about themselves and take the dividend
from the extra tax revenues coming in
and dedicate a good portion of that to
paying down the debt so chicken of the
first you grow the economy then you take
a dividend to pay down the debt on a
regular basis is there anything to be
learned from California's financial
situation these days for President Obama
yeah I think it there is I mean I think
you you can't let your debt get out of
hand because we get it out of hand it's
like get to use a show how old or it's
like a pacman it just swallows you and
you're going not Greece you're going so
rare is very important you keep an eye
on two things at once growth putting
people back to work and taking a good
chunk of the dividend of that growth and
allocating into debt reduction you have
had a lot of interaction with public
sector unions over the years what have
you learned and what what can you what
can you say about public sector unions
and their role in and financial
situations well public sector unions
have every right to plead their case
before public officials but like any
other
important constituency they can't
overtax the system and 10 20 years ago
we made promises that we thought the
economy could support turns out it could
not so you clearly can't ask the
taxpayers to reach in your pocket and
pay even more than they're currently
paying for pensions that's why we have
to bring pensions back in life
eventually I think we'll start to move
away from a defined benefit pension to
one which is a more hybrid situation
where everyone takes the risk of the
stock market and the investment
portfolio if it was better than expected
by your pension is better equipped
there's worse than expected you don't do
as well as you like but the whole idea
is you don't ship the risk to the tax
bridge do you have any reservations
about dispensary raids on marijuana
dispensaries in California from the
Justice Department something that
present Obama said he would stop too he
would stop when he came into office you
know I was against the medical marijuana
provision because while I believe
there's a legitimate right for people
who have a doctor's prescription
specifically for medical marijuana to
have access to it that an issue was
written so broadly and if you just think
your doctor would have given you one if
you'd asked which you did not you get to
marijuana so it would just suck refuse
to legalize marijuana which I do not fit
but it but it is law now and these raids
are still happening yes it's law but you
know we still have the Supremacy Clause
in the Constitution and if federal got
they feel that federal law is being
violated have a right to do what they're
a power to duty am I happy about it no
other things people could focus on the
Justice Department I would think so but
that's what happens when you pass a law
the contradict federal wall you run the
risk the feds might disagree